this video is sponsored by nordvpn
hunter hunter has a better start to its
story
than most manga i've ever read dragon
ball
one piece jojo's bizarre adventure all
of those eventually got amazing but from
right out the gate i sincerely believe
hunter hunter has reached a level of
nuance and complexity far quicker
and in a much more entertaining fashion
early on having been born and raised in
ireland
shows like dragon ball yugioh digimon
beyblade and even metabots made their
respective cultural impacts here
shows like one piece however didn't
catch on nearly as much around my neck
of the woods though i do remember it
being spoken about here and there from
time to time
but hunter hunter i never even heard of
this thing until maybe my second year of
college and by that point i was busy
failing my exams so i never watched it
fast forward to present day
thousands of recommendations later while
i still have little to no knowledge of
this story
i find myself both excited and nervous
excited because this is one of the most
highly regarded shonen properties out
there
with many telling me that aspects of it
are better than one piece now we'll see
if that's true but
i'm also nervous because this series has
a bit of a reputation that comes along
with it
a reputation that might prove to be a
difficult obstacle once i really start
to get into
the meat of this series
but i'll never shy away from my
challenge just like my one piece reviews
no matter what stands in my way i intend
to catch up with this critically
acclaimed and globally beloved story
in the only fashion i know how by
sharing this adventure
with all of you so everyone i hope
you're ready because these are my first
impressions of
thoughts on and review for the beautiful
the whimsical and the subtly tragic tale
of a young boy
in search of his father this is my blind
review
of hunter hunter's hunter exam arch
[Music]
day
hunter hunter has a wonderful exciting
and
horrifyingly scary world the title
hunter is a broad term used to identify
someone that's passed the hunter exam
and often specializes in different
fields and there are
lots of murders in this hunter exam a
series of ludicrously intense challenges
testing physical mental and
emotional strength are pitted against
its examinees
of which most drop out or die i think
the passing rate is something like one
in one hundred thousand
this is the goal of the first arc for
our main character
gun to attain his hunter license
as i mentioned in the opening of this
video the pacing of the story was
what surprised me and impressed me the
most over the years i've gotten used to
there being a sort of warm-up period
where the author either discovers what
works or sets up the necessary pieces
for down the line both of these can feel
significantly less fun than the latter
part of the series when placed alongside
for comparison
however hunter hunter it got going
really really quick and by the second or
third chapter i was fully engaged
it is worth noting however that unlike
akira toriyama who's previously written
a successful story yes
but in an entirely different genre and
oda who'd done one shots before his
outing with one piece
tagashi had already penned the massively
successful yuuyu haku show making him a
very seasoned and successful writer
within this
genre and already a master of his craft
ghan's introduction to this story
unlike many manga mcs that get a quick
upbeat inciting incident with bouts of
momentary sad elements
hunter hunter instead feels like it's a
story trying to convince me it's about
adventure and friendship primarily but
in reality has some very serious themes
of fatherhood
family and abandonment lurking right
beneath the surface of its pages
and it's that unease and subtle hint of
poison in its text
that kept me very interested
particularly in the early and latter
stages of this arc specifically
this unease and awareness of this
element also helped to highlight for me
at the least
just how wonderful of a character gone
is
and the first chapter is great in this
respect in addition to learning about
his desire to pass the hunter exams and
to become a hunter all in an effort to
find his possibly estranged father
there are pockets of certain key scenes
where gun demonstrates
qualities yet unknown to me that inform
actual hunters like kite
that gun is in fact a person of interest
someone worth keeping tabs on but
all of that aside one specific scene
that got me on gun's side immediately
has to be when he chose to protect that
wild baby animal
despite it being painful and difficult
he doesn't want to leave something on
its own
a not so subtle metaphor signifying
perhaps what might be to come
and shockingly this i would think
crucial scene
is cut from the most recent anime and
it's for reasons like this
i will always choose to read the manga
as my primary source
gone has an emotional story ahead of him
and i feel like it's going to be
torturous so i want to have the most
accurate interpretation of that story
that i can also whenever father figures
are involved in a coming-of-age story
like this i am always a ball of emotions
and i know something big is on the
horizon here so i want to make sure that
i get the experience tagashi wanted me
to
unlike many shonen heroes gone's primary
goal isn't to necessarily become a
highly reputable or
impressive hunter but to reach and
reconnect with his father
unlike dragon ball one piece where the
protagonists have much more traditional
shonen goals
in hunter hunter the typical shonen goal
is no longer a goal but
a vehicle towards a much more
complicated and
emotional one becoming a hunter isn't
the goal it's a lodging off point
towards something much more important to
him and
i thought that was pretty interesting
he's a strong character determined kind
and boasting a tremendous attitude and
these chapters managed to endear me to
gone almost immediately and that's
important because
as the arc quickly progresses into god's
adventure with the hunter exams
he ends up sharing more of the spotlight
than you might expect the main
protagonist to share
thankfully however those he shares the
screen with are fantastic additions to
help
round out the cast enter lyorio and
kurapika
once again this is where i think
togashi's brilliant and much welcomed
desire to show
and not tell comes into focus early on
in these stories a lot of the exposition
about a given character is
often clunky serving the purpose of
getting the boring pieces of information
out of the way as quickly as possible
thus giving our main character reason to
recruit them
or have them follow along on their
journey one piece tells us a lot about
the reputation and ability zoro has
before we ever meet him and this is what
draws luffy to
zorro in the first place in dragon ball
goku joins bulma in what will eventually
become a big adventure
after she divulges the necessary
information all this is
honestly perfectly serviceable but in
hunter hunter
togashi doesn't tell us who leorio or
kuropika are right off the bat
and in fact there's no clunky means with
which they come into contact
at all gone is simply on a ship bound
for the hunter exams and the rocky seas
incapacitate
all but the three of them as it happens
those rough seas were part of the
preliminary
hunter exams themselves meaning the
qualities that make these characters
who they are is what created the natural
circumstances that led to their eventual
meeting
and this is achieved without any words
it's brilliant furthermore their
relationship and role in this opening
scene together i believe
beautifully foreshadows something
important to come okay so
hear me out when one of the crew members
falls overboard during the storm
altogether the three of them leap
forward towards the fallen crew member
now this obviously tells us a lot about
these characters personalities and their
willingness to put themselves in danger
to protect someone in trouble but
i noticed maybe something else despite
being in a worse position to reach the
crew member on time
gone still manages to reach his target
or goal before kuropika and lyorio can
however it is still up to leorio and
corepika to each grab one of gon's legs
and pull him back
onto the ship metaphorically speaking
this could be interpreted as
gone is gifted and therefore has the
potential to go farther than both of
them
but can't last on his own he needs them
to ground him
and protect him when he overextends
himself without gone the man would have
fallen overboard to his death
and without quarter pika and leorio gone
may very well have died trying to save
that man
in other words they need each other it's
a brilliant scene and these are just the
first two chapters
we have our goal to pass the hunter exam
and to use that as a platform to find
jing gon's father we have this new group
of friends to follow
gon a character i know will make me cry
at least once before this video is done
and two tremendous supporting characters
in the brainy and noble corepika
and the brash but kind leorio
particularly the instances here and
there sprinkle throughout where gun
shows that he's just a decent person
i adore being the only one to thank the
sea captain after he lands the ship
leading that very sea captain to point
him in the right direction
once again reaffirming that the
impressive physical attributes of gun
are not all that's being judged here but
okay enough beating around the bush
it's time to get into the real meat and
potatoes of this arc it's time
for the real hunter exam challenges
the following challenges all offer
something very different
and this is particularly what makes this
section of the story so
damn fun one chapter is spent trying to
figure out a dilemma posed by an old
lady
another is a whodunit mystery with a
cabin in the woods and
another is a whole lot of running and
these are just but a few
of the first ones all these challenges
are funny or engaging in their own
respective ways but
the real reason they're there is to
offer us as an audience a number of
unique and great opportunities to get to
know
these characters just that little bit
more personally and this works as
effectively as it does because a number
of these challenges are specifically
designed in universe to give the hunter
association a means with which to judge
each of their personalities
and by association we the audience gain
that insight too whether that be through
figuring out lyorio's initial shallow
motivation to earn money
actually comes from an altruistic place
in wanting to help people as a doctor
or corepika who's driven by an intense
urge to avenge his people's massacre to
all of these characters the hunter
license doesn't represent the ultimate
goal but
a means to an end goal something they
all
share in common which plays a large role
in the success of my favorite early
challenge the running segment
it's beyond ridiculous speaking of
someone that did a bit of running in the
past the very concept of this
follow the leader running challenge made
me laugh out loud at the sheer scale and
preposterousness of the event
it's it's it's just so damn long it's
like an
ultra marathon but at marathon length
olympian level pace
consistently after running the
equivalent of two and a half marathons
in around
six hours the first person drops out as
the rest of the examinees ridicule him
for not being enough
i'm sorry i didn't realize everyone
running in this race is literally elliot
kipchoge on steroids i mean
they didn't need to drink water or eat
food or
anything thankfully though i get my
representation amongst these demigods of
athletics
through the humble lay oreo who like a
normal human being is struggling
massively but putting on a brave face
it's mystery and speaking of the oreo
this is where i learned to love him his
tenacity and desire to not appear lesser
than the rest is stupendously fun in
tandem with his hilarious depiction in
the manga
running shirtless i mean the dude runs
like three sub three hour marathons back
to back all the while carrying his
briefcase
what an absolute chat asaurus rex
what i found interesting was that at a
number of times throughout these various
challenges
multiple individuals remark in amazement
at what gun
is able to do whether it be athletically
how well he can hear
see or even taste his abilities when
performing was asked often during these
challenges hint
at least to me towards something
specifically special about
gun though nothing that outshines his
personality and attitude towards
conflict and his friends
[Music]
if you're looking for a vpn service
provider nordvpn is what i prefer using
the most
whether it be keeping your personal
information from the scary world of the
internet or you're like me
and really want to unlock some of that
region lock goodness on netflix
seriously i need it if you need anything
like that nordvpn's got you covered on
both your desktop and your mobile phone
with its easy to use
application all i've got to do is just
click on one of the many servers in a
different country and boom
it works like a charm and i can take my
delusions to another level by pretending
i'm on vacation in that country and
not trapped inside my room due to the
ongoing current global crisis
right now you can get a two-year plan at
a huge discount at nordvpn.com
totally not mark and use coupon code
totally not mark to get one additional
month free and you're not risking
anything with nord's 30-day money-back
guarantee
i particularly like it for its
peer-to-peer sharing so downloading
torrents is much more safe and secure
which nord makes exceptionally easy by
downloading the extension onto my
browser
all of this coupled with 24-hour
customer service at your disposal you're
in the best of care so if you want to be
in control of your internet experience
head on over to nordvpn.com
totally not mark to take control of your
internet again
he chose being a hunter over his own son
yeah isn't that amazing
[Music]
outside of the much appreciated and
humorous cooking challenge i thought two
instances stood out to me as
the most noteworthy and it has to do
with the character of kilua
much the same way as i outlined before
we learn about kilowatt not through
clunky exposition but
instead quite interestingly by the
choices he makes or
doesn't make when faced with conflict in
this arc killua at this time in the
story seems to me to be tied with gone
thematically they first meet at the
beginning of the great
run and during it become fast friends
however when faced with the dilemma of
staying with kilauea charging ahead or
going back to help his friends gunn
without hesitation
goes back for his friends leorio and
corepika
landing one of the most satisfying hits
i've ever experienced so early in a
series
making the save for leorio against the
creepy clown man hisoka
okay more on him a little later again
just to reiterate this is still
ridiculously early on in the story and
already i'm so invested in tagashi's
writing that
shots like this make me squeal with
delight a sign of things to come i hope
but
at this point however i didn't recognize
this particular decision as
anything significant to kilauea until
i found this scene to be very telling
while in transit to their next challenge
and while everyone is sleeping from
the great run the chairman of the hunter
association challenges gone and killua
to a game of ball
the object being if they can get the
ball away from him then they win
while offering a fun visual and
distraction from the past contests
this particular challenge is also a
great mechanism to help us as an
audience to further distinguish between
gun and kilauea in both approach and
personality through the eyes of the
terror we learn that kilauea has
assassin type skills but perhaps most
interestingly
as soon as killua gets an indication
that the old guy is far above his level
and that he cannot possibly win
he gives up but gun keeps trying
meaning it doesn't matter to god one way
or the other if he can win or not he
just wants to best himself this helps to
build the dark aura around kilauea and
brightens guns respectively reinforced
moments later by this horrific panel
depicting killer was slaughtering a
bunch of people
in the hallway and then it made me think
every time
gone and kilauea separate after their
eventual meeting
it's due to some key character
differences between them instead of
keeping his head in the game towards the
front of the pack with killua
gun went back to save his friends and
instead of giving up in the face of
seemingly insurmountable odds like
kilauea did gone stuck it out and
eventually improved upon his prior
efforts
i love killua's character he's in many
ways an inversion of the gun character
with enough in common to build a
believable friendship between the two
he's got a dark past and as we later
learned down the line
this is primarily due to a troubled
family history huh
a lot like god in that respect also an
interesting relationship most definitely
and
things only get more intense as we make
our way through the final
three phases this is the single longest
challenge presented to our team so far
chronicled across eight individual
chapters our heroes end up grouping
together to overcome the unique
challenges this tower presents
as they endeavor to make it all the way
to the bottom in the allotted time
the team is composed of gun kilauea
kurapika and leorio
all characters we are happy with but the
conflict in this story comes about as
the rookie crusher joins the team living
up to the name he pretty much tries to
sabotage everything
and i hate him in this tower of trickery
there's really only two natural points
of noteworthy conflict the first takes
place in a form of a 5v5 contest as our
team of examinees square up against
five prisoners looking to waste as much
time as possible so that they can get
that time off of their sentences
welcome to hunter hunter where children
get to fight literal
in-universe psychopaths and murderers
for their very lives
there's a great mix of lighthearted
comedy clever mystery writing and even
some great action
and so first up is the rookie crusher
looking to show his team that he's
actually a team
just kidding he quits i i don't know
what you could have been expecting here
all right the score right here is 0-1 in
favor of the prisoners and the second
round sees gun participate in a weird
candle holding game to be honest
i really enjoyed this one it was
strangely effective in building tension
and what's more is
gon found a quick and clever solution to
this worsening scenario
he's not a dumb guy scores even at one
to one a piece
third up on the hero team is kurapika
this one
really offers him a chance to explore
his more aggressive side i never
mentioned this but he becomes enraged or
emotionally compromised when his eyes
glow red
and he'll show very little restraint
when they do so
as an audience we knew this about
kuropika before the fight began and so
when it comes to our attention that the
dude he's facing doesn't have any
intention of coming to blows and
is in fact a coward we know things
aren't going to end well
for him and this is where things got a
little clever
deviating from the simple formula and
starting to become less predictable
there's some clever manipulation of the
rules during this portion corpico won't
kill him and so
all this dude's gotta do is play dead
having leorio carry out this deed is a
great choice from an audience standpoint
kuropika
already proved to us that he's awesome
and so didn't need to finish him we all
knew that he could
and because leorio's section ultimately
ends in failure and relies largely on
comedy lyorio's quick solution to get
kuropika the victory helped to even out
his worth in my mind
it's a small thing but these are
decisions that make or break comedic
scenarios had leorio done nothing to
help his team prior to throwing so
so many points away in exchange for
touching a breast
those funnier moments would have a
greater chance of coming across as
annoying
in retrospect in short the victory
leorio got for kuropika is as much his
and the loss is also his and so now with
the contest all
even it comes down to this bruiser of a
prison killawa wins i mean come on
the kid's a cold-blooded killer what did
you expect he literally stole his heart
[ __ ] metals now this is where we get
to my favorite part of this
challenge the guys are left with one
last decision a choice between two
passageways
one will allow only some of them to make
it in time and the other one they could
all take but it's a significantly longer
trek and they definitely won't make it
in time if they take that route
now in preparation for this first review
i was shown some of the anime's key
moments from this arc and
this was one of them and funnily enough
the anime both in the 1999 version and
the 2011 version
make this scene i think worse and gone
less intelligent or impressive in the
manga gun pieces together a solution to
their issue that gets
everyone there on time and he comes up
with this when he sees the weapons on
the wall and recalls that those they
faced in the previous contest
managed to break the ground or rocks
around them using
only their hands and so using that piece
of info coupled with this dilemma they
have he devises a plan to tunnel from
the bad path to the good path
everyone wins genius decision i was very
impressed
but in both anime adaptations instead of
recalling this vital piece of
information from earlier in the
challenge leorio and the others start
fighting amongst themselves and that's
when he notices the weapons break the
ground that way it's
significantly less impressive both from
a writing standpoint and a god
standpoint he never had to recall any
information and repurpose it he just saw
it and just made the connection there
and then it's a fun scene in both the
manga and the anime but the manga does
this much better i think and with that
said the hunter
and the hunted this challenge has a
really exciting premise that pits
unlikely opponents against each other
it's a manhunt of sorts where each
contender is given an id badge
representing themselves each candidate
then draws lots and
through this they randomly receive their
individual target if they have their own
id badge by the end that's three points
if they get their targets id badge by
the end that's an additional three
points every badge in your possession
that isn't yours or your targets you get
one point and you need
six to pass overall it's such a fun game
and gun drew hisoka
this hisoka clown guy is drawn all sorts
of creepy and
the way he participates in these ongoing
challenges as the numbers whittle down
more and more
becomes somewhat intimidating and for
the first time since gun made the save
in la oreo during the running segment
actually managing to land a shot on
hisoka and getting super scared of the
weird killer clown man
gun has to face his fear and through his
own strategy has to figure out how to
best
the clear front runner among the
remaining contestants kilowatt goes
about things on his own
to great success but gun and hisoka
pretty much play a role in everyone
else's business at one point or another
during this contest
there's some supremely creepy imagery as
ghan is forced to stalk hisoka
for days waiting for the perfect chance
to land the steel and even then
after the fact the only reason gan got
to keep the id was because hisoka was
impressed with his patience and skill in
securing the initial tag
leaving gon to reflect on all the
mistakes he made leading up to that
point it's a big growing moment for gone
i also like this section because we got
to see the blossoming bromance between
kuropika and leorio develop
even further and if the previous
challenges and chapters leading up to
this one didn't demonstrate the
wonderful friendship these three all
have then the ending for this particular
phase will secure that particular hang
up for you
as all their individual character traits
aid in solving the cave snake problem
they found themselves in towards the end
but long story short togashi is goaded
and everyone moves on to the next and
final round
including this weird frankenstein
looking dude that's been looking creepy
for a while now
and of course hisoka is there among a
few others
[Music]
this was a moment i wasn't prepared for
and one that makes a lot of sense when
taking into account the greater context
of the story there's a sort of
melancholic maturity to gone as a
character
he's a sort of tragic and lonely
protagonist it really helps to bolster
why he doesn't want to be alone and even
sheds light as to why he sought out
kuropika and leorio after he had already
passed the previous round he's a lonely
soul and
wants to feel worthwhile and that's
i don't even know what to say to that i
love gun
and it's amazing what's been achieved
with his character in just the first arc
of the series
and takashi isn't done surprisingly with
him either yet
not by a long shot time for the final
phase now there's only one step standing
between our heroes
and their licenses to be hunters and
tagashi ops to utilize the most
traditional shonen challenge here for
this final phase a series of one-on-one
fights and he decides to present it in a
rather
unconventional way one of the aspects
that i thought was sort of
neat was how in addition to intelligence
and physical awareness being judged and
intangible was taken into consideration
when drawing up the brackets
and as a result of this intangible gun
got one of the most favorable and
forgiving of placings
all they have to do is win one fight to
get their respective licenses and guns
placing here means that he could afford
to lose a number of contests and still
have a chance to get his license in the
end
and first up he has to fight hanzo the
ninja
this fight is brutal with a capital b
the only way someone can win is if their
opponent quits and
shockingly despite seeing him overcome
most physical challenges with apparent
ease
gun is put on the back foot and tortured
physically from the moment the fight
begins
hanzo is demonstrably more skilled in
combat and through a series of
at times difficult to watch scenarios
hanzo inflicts more pain unto god in
three
hours than many might receive in their
lifetimes watching on in horror and
anger kurupeek and leorio are on the
verge of throwing away what they have
and interfering with the fight
fearing that god's life is at stake here
and then
we get to chapter 34. and to be
perfectly clear here
chapters like this don't normally affect
me the way this one has
i've been blown away by chapters
characters and events in one piece an
absurd amount of times and
while moments from that series broke me
down emotionally with relentless sadness
all of those moments in one piece that
made me emotional
in one way or another on some level even
if it's my news
i felt coming ever so slightly but with
this chapter
i was completely taken off guard
something i want to bring to your
attention is that i don't write these
scripts as i read and
at this point in the story i had
completely forgotten what gon said or
outlined in chapter one regarding his
motivation and so
when hanzo begins berating gone and
asking if his pride is the reason he
won't quit
my mind sort of reverted to what i
expect from other shonen a lot of
stories
in this genre tend to value and praise
pridefulness or a pride in oneself
and truth be told even as a dragon ball
fan i've never liked the idea of
embracing pride that way there's a
terrific quote from avatar the last
airbender wherein
iro says pride is not the opposite of
shame but
its source and that statement is
true however much to my surprise after
three hours of a one-sided beatdown
after
breaking gunn's arm in two hanzo shouts
is your pride all you care about even
more than your own life
cutting through the silence god quietly
responds
i want to see my dad six words and i was
left utterly speechless
expecting one thing out of habit and
familiarity with this genre and
instead received a sobering wake-up call
that this story
hunter hunter is something truly special
one piece is phenomenal and owns its own
identity dragon ball is the same it's
phenomenal and owns its own identity
and right here hunter hunter cemented
for me
its very own identity it's unlike
anything i've ever read
what an incredibly strong character and
one of the most relatable
and likable personalities i've ever come
across that in just six words
immediately recontextualized the fight
and made it the most
emotionally rich experience a first arc
of any story
has given me i do not have words and so
please take the time if you haven't
already
to read or watch this for yourselves
it's truly something special and one i
will not forget
[Music]
this was a very surprising but welcome
swerve instead of tackling the events of
the tournament after the emotional high
of that last bout takashi decided to
conclude the tournament off-screen
while giving us the surprising and
tragic outcomes of the event from ghan's
perspective
as he awakens from his bout kilauea
failed and killed someone choices in
structuring your story like togashi has
made here is but one of the many choices
that afforded this story the breezy and
enjoyable pacing it boasts
naturally i have so many questions
concerning the future of kilauea and
as i learn what happened piece by piece
the truly creepy nature behind kilauea's
family
partially reveals itself lending insight
into what likely is the source of all
the pain he's demonstrated through this
first arc with his brother brandishing
philosophies that match
up exactly to his attitude in quitting
early in the ballgame it's unsettling to
see what sort of hold illumi has over
kilowatt and the reaction god has to the
event once he learns what happened
much like gun killua is a kid looking
for connection a connection
gon leorio and kuropika assure
that they share with him to his brother
[Music]
this is the first time i've seen god
take action against somebody that
clearly is
levels above where most people are
currently at this point in time
in an aggressive and angry way a
character like ahsoka particularly
leading up to and
during the forest id hunt contest ghan
was visibly shaken by his initial
encounter with the crazed clown and
rightfully so
he's terrifying and in response to this
gone had to practice a very specific
skill to facilitate a strategic and
well-placed steel
which he eventually succeeds in
performing however when it comes to
illumi kilauea's brother
gon literally breaks his arm after
grabbing it in
anger and after this reprimanding illumi
lets hisoka know that he now
understands what he sees in him
throughout this arc from various
characters point of view they've all
cited that with gun there is something
very special with the sea captain even
being reminded of one particular person
i assume this is jing there's a power in
gone that has yet to fully surface and
it'll be interesting to see how this
story continues to explore that
particularly because we understand how
emotionally rich some of the subject
matter here
is with that said despite leorio kurpika
and gone having received their hunter
licenses in this instance
the ending to this arc is one of
bitterness and concern for the future of
their friend and perhaps most
interestingly kite
the hunter that encountered ghan in
chapter 1 left him his father's
card what that means for the future i
can say for sure but
as the heroes of this journey begin
making their way towards kilauea's
family home
i can't help but feel the excitement in
me build as i ponder what awaits these
phenomenally realized characters in the
future
now having finished this arc and
thinking back over what i've read i'm
left
dumbfounded not only at the pacing of
events but this feeling of familiarity i
now associate with this series
the characters are wonderfully funny
interesting and heartwarming in equal
measure with a sort of tragedy that
manages to seep through the pages
if you look out for it or think about it
for long enough this arc alone had
moments that had me on the edge of my
seat and have me shedding tears for
characters i've only just recently
gotten to know i can only assume this is
a great sign of things to come and if
hunter hunter can keep things
up it might very well measure up to one
piece in my estimation but
it is still very early days yet and
these characters have only just started
this no doubt long
and harrowing journey of self-discovery
but
what a start it has been
[Music]
foreign